[Music]
on this Tuesday night Donald Trump
charged with criminal offenses
the case against the former president
plus the security concerns and dueling
demonstrations gruesome fined at a
Manitoba landfill the investigation into
the discovery of another indigenous
woman's body
protesters raising awareness about human
rights abuses in China the allegations
they've been harassed here in Canada for
speaking out it is widespread
and Failure to Launch why virgins rocket
business has plummeted into bankruptcy
global national with Donna Friesen high
drama in a New York City courtroom today
former U.S president Donald Trump is now
a defendant in a criminal case charged
with 34 felony counts no other former
U.S president has ever been in this
situation good evening and thanks for
joining us Trump pleaded not guilty to
all counts today the case centers on an
alleged scheme that involved falsifying
business records to bury negative
stories about Trump before the 2016
election Trump on social media had
already claimed the case is political
and accused the New York district
attorney of being a psychopath the onus
is now on Trump himself who is running
for president again to defend himself in
court Jackson prosco is in Manhattan
tonight Jackson
Donna Donald Trump's remarkable day in
court lasted far longer than expected
tonight the district attorney is giving
us a better look at the charges he now
faces and what they say is New Evidence
underlying the case
this was the moment Donald Trump entered
the history books in court and under
arrest as the first former president
charged with a crime
he left his Manhattan penthouse by
motorcade posting to his social media
seemed so surreal wow they are going to
arrest me
soon after he turned himself into the
Manhattan district attorney
he was immediately fingerprinted and
processed and then arraigned before a
judge he pleaded not guilty to 34 counts
relating to falsifying business records
the charges sent her around alleged hush
money payments to two women and a
doorman before the 2016 election this is
frustrated he's upset but I'll tell you
what
what happened it's not going down every
charge is a felony part of an alleged
conspiracy to bury negative stories that
could have hurt Trump's campaign under
New York state law it is a felony to
falsify business records with intent of
Fraud and an intent to conceal another
crime
outside the court security concerns kept
police on edge as dueling rallies put
America's political divide on display
and if they enjoyed him and hold him and
charge him with bogus charges he was
pressed and me as a citizen we will
never be free but today is a very
serious day in our country it's a
historic day we're finally somebody with
so much power the ex-president is going
to be arrested and hopefully held
accountable for his crimes against women
and we hope that this is the first of
his crimes that he will be prosecuted
Trump was kept at a distance from the
crowds released pending trial the
charges will feature heavily in his
re-election campaign
there had been questions as to whether
or not the former president would be
subjected to some sort of gag order to
prevent him from discussing the case in
light of his inflammatory comments about
both the district attorney and the judge
who is hearing this trial but Donna that
wasn't brought to fruition today instead
the judge cautioned all parties against
saying anything that could incite their
supporters toward violence okay and
Trump back in Palm Beach Florida tonight
Jackson in New York thanks just north of
Winnipeg there's been a tragic Discovery
at a landfill an indigenous woman has
been found dead she's been identified as
33-year-old Linda Mary beardy
investigators say she was not a missing
person they believe her body was dumped
at the landfill by a garbage truck a few
hours before staff at the landfill found
it on Monday afternoon police say they
consider beardy's death suspicious they
are not classifying it as a homicide her
death is not believed to be connected to
any other investigations or the alleged
serial killings last year that left four
indigenous women dead a 35 year old
Winnipeg man is charged with first
degree murder in those cases the
Assembly of First Nations has endorsed
an expanded 23 billion dollar settlement
to compensate those involved in the
child welfare system the deal is a
result of two class-action lawsuits over
harm done to indigenous children and
their families because of the federal
government's chronic underfunding of on
reserve Child and Family Services the
revised agreement which includes more
than thirteen thousand children left out
of the original agreement boost total
compensation by three billion dollars
this in some ways is a sad day because
when you pay compensation it means that
the child has lost their childhood and
that could have been prevented and I
want to see this being the very last
compensation payment for children that
Canada ever makes because I'd never want
to see our kids victimized again
the settlement still needs approval from
the human rights tribunal and the
federal court if it goes ahead forty
thousand dollars in payments could be
distributed to eligible claimants
starting later this year
a Quebec man accused of driving his
pickup truck into pedestrians in the
town of amqui now faces murder charges
Steve Gagnon was charged with three
counts of first-degree murder and nine
counts of attempted murder police say
the 38-year-old intentionally drove a
pickup truck into a group of pedestrians
on March 13th he was initially charged
with dangerous driving causing death
Chinese Canadians who dare to speak out
against the Chinese Communist Party can
face daily distressing consequences
threatening phone calls property damage
family members in China arrested or sent
to labor camps the victims often include
oppressed minority and religious groups
such as uighurs or followers of the
spiritual group falun gong they say
they've reported the abuse for years as
Jeff Semple reports they say their cries
for help are finally being heard
they're a familiar sight on Canadian
city streets followers of falun gong
meditating and raising awareness about
human rights abuses in China the Chinese
government which restricts religious
freedoms banned the spiritual practice
24 years ago and calls the group an evil
cult
I was arrested twice in China for
practicing falun gong police followed me
everywhere says kyushaisha she escaped
to Canada in 2014 but never expected
beijing's Shadow would follow her here
we are photographed and harassed every
week she says
hello Global News spoke with more than a
dozen falun gong followers and other
members of the Chinese diaspora who say
they faced surveillance intimidation and
abuse here in Canada after speaking out
against the Chinese Communist Party most
didn't want to show their faces because
they have family in China
foreign
says her family has nothing left to lose
this persecution Must Be Stopped Zhang
left China in 1998 just before beijing's
Crackdown on falun gong soon after her
brother-in-law was sent to a labor camp
where he died then her sister went
missing leaving behind a two-year-old
daughter
just before her sister disappeared she
called Jonathan and left this voicemail
in the message her sister describes in
detail the persecution of falun gong
followers in China which at the time
wasn't well documented every day I was
in tears I was a very very difficult
time for me
Zhang went public with her sister's
story and protested outside the Chinese
Consulate soon after she says her car
parked outside her Vancouver apartment
had its Windows smashed a man banged on
her front door threatening her children
and human excrement was dumped onto her
first floor balcony I suddenly found all
the human feces everywhere on the
balcony
that was very very weird I had no
enemies in that City I realized that the
the Chinese Communist party was probably
the
um the one who was directing this whole
thing but she has no proof she reported
the incidents to police to no avail and
she's not alone it is widespread and the
main task it seems to us is to
intimidate and instill fear within
diaspora members residing in Canada this
uyghur leader says the community has
been sounding the alarm for years he
hopes now following the recent
Revelations about China's political
interference in Canada people will take
their concerns more seriously it is very
regrettable that it took someone from
ceases to deliberately leak this
information it seems to me that they
felt the same as we do frustration or
over inaction the Chinese Consulate did
not respond to our request for comment
but it has consistently denied
allegations of intimidation and
interference campaigns claiming they're
nothing more than attempts to sabotage
the prosperity and stability of China
Donna Jeff sample in Toronto tonight
thanks Russian investigators have
charged a 26 year old woman with
terrorism in the death of a prominent
pro-war military blogger Daria tripova
appeared in a Moscow Court accused in
the cafe bombing that killed vladen
tatarsky in St Petersburg on Sunday he
was meeting with supporters and more
than 30 people were injured Russia
released video of tripova likely
recorded under duress admitting she
brought a statuette to the cafe that
later blew up she said she did not know
it would explode Russia claims Ukrainian
intelligence orchestrated the attack
Ukraine hasn't directly responded to
that
an historic moment for Finland and for
NATO today
after Decades of remaining neutral
Finland has joined NATO its flag hoisted
beside the 30 other members of the
world's biggest security Alliance the
Nordic Nation decided to join after
Russia launched its full-scale invasion
of Ukraine last year it means NATO's
land border with Russia has now doubled
Eric Sorensen explains the significance
of this big geopolitical shift
NATO wasted no time convening its first
meeting with Finland as a member
it is a great day for Finland
security and stability are those
Elements which we feel
very strongly Finland will get an iron
CAD security guarantee Article 5 our
Collective defense Clause one for all
for one I will now from today apply for
Finland
Finland has a strong Armed Forces with
military conscription and thousands of
reservists but after years as fiercely
unaligned Finland finally saw in Russia
an existential threat since understood
that if you are a military non-allied
country next to a nuclear power that
talks about the use of nuclear Powers
you really need to get to under a
nuclear umbrella yourself as well
Russia's Vladimir Putin did not comment
on NATO's latest expansion while touring
a rail Factory but he is well aware of
Russia's territorial losing streak
against the alliance at one time Russia
created and controlled the Soviet Union
more than a dozen republics including
Ukraine and the Soviet Union established
the Warsaw Pact adding seven more
European countries under its influence
an iron curtain separating them from
NATO but the Soviet Union broke apart
Eastern European countries began to join
NATO as did some former Soviet republics
Russia did not want Ukraine to be one
more yet its War there has prompted
unaligned Finland to join NATO right on
Russia's border Finland would never have
done this had it not been for Russia's
aggression against Ukraine so this is a
matter of
Putin creating more insecurity for
himself through the aggression that he's
uh visited upon his neighbor
Canada's foreign affairs minister said
NATO hope Sweden will be next to join
but it's Finland where the change is
profound its long border now on the
front lines between NATO and Russia Eric
Sorensen Global News Toronto
as the push grows to invest in green
energy a Canadian bank is helping fund a
coal mine operator how that company says
the money is being spent coming up
[Music]
data obtained by global news shows RBC
is one of 25 banks that help provide
more than 5 billion dollars U.S in
financing to a German company expanding
a controversial Coal Mine police removed
climate activists including Greta
tunberg from that site earlier this year
and last month the U.N Secretary General
Antonio Gutierrez demanded an end to the
funding of coal projects so that
countries can meet their emissions
reduction targets Redmond Shannon
reports
in January thousands of people gathered
in a soggy field in Western Germany to
try and stop the expansion of a huge
Coal Mine money camped out for months in
a village set to be demolished as part
of the expansion among those detained by
police the world's most famous climate
activist Greta tunberg and as long as
today the garzweiler lignite mine
stretches across 35 square kilometers
producing 30 million tons of coal a year
its expansion Westward needed the
Villages of luzarat and emirat to be
vacated now that they are mine operator
and German energy giant rwe can soon dig
for coal Global News has learned from
financial data firm refinitive that in
2022 Canada's largest bank RBC was among
25 banks that combined to offer credit
lines worth more than 5 billion U.S
dollars to rwe that despite a public
commitment by RBC in 2020 to restrict
some funding of companies opening new
coal mines but that policy doesn't
necessarily apply to companies expanding
Minds Richard Brooks is the climate
Finance director with environmental NGO
stand Earth well you look at all the
policies that the Canadian banks have in
regards to coal and they have so many
loopholes in them that you could drive a
coal excavator through those loopholes
RBC told Global News it doesn't comment
on client matters rwe told global news
that the money is used to finance green
growth and normal working capital needs
the company says the mine expansion is
needed to protect Germany's energy
security and Supply as the war in
Ukraine rages on Brooks says rwe can do
whatever it wants with the credit lines
there's no restrictions put in place to
ensure that money is going into climate
solution or Renewables project and what
takes a lot of money is expanding fossil
fuel infrastructure Brooks and others
lodged a complaint with the Canadian
competition Bureau last year concerning
alleged deceptive marketing practices at
RBC regarding its climate claims the
bureau's investigation is ongoing RBC
says it believes the complaint to be
unfair founded data shows the credit
lines were classified as sustainability
linked loans a type of loan designed to
incentivize companies to meet certain
green or sustainable targets like
increasing the use of Renewables but
rwe's targets are self-imposed if you're
your own referee right you're not going
to penalize yourself or put yourself in
a corner even if it's in the public
interest to reduce you know exposure to
fossil fuels you're going to do what's
the profitable thing Tariq fancy is a
former investment banker with BlackRock
the world's largest asset manager he is
now a Critic of the current rules
governing sustainable Finance I call it
putting green paint on existing
Financial products at RBC RBC has set a
goal of half a trillion dollars in
sustainable financing by 2025 but the
bank remains one of the world's biggest
investors in fossil fuel projects fancy
says tougher rules are needed to
discourage that it has to be government
regulation it has to be mandatory
compliance rather than voluntary
compliance because we can't rely on them
voluntarily to do that because it's not
in their financial interest and they're
not built to do that in the meantime RBC
shareholders will vote on committing to
more concrete emission investment
targets at its AGM on Wednesday Redmond
Channel and Global News London
after Decades of lobbying ahead which
province will benefit from the expansion
of the federal shipbuilding plan
[Music]
the federal government has reached a
deal to add Quebec Shipyard chantier
Davie as the third Shipyard in its
multi-billion dollar ship procurement
plan it was excluded from the original
shipbuilding plan back in 2011.
there was work that needed to be done
needed to be done rigorously to
demonstrate among other things that
there was going to be sufficient amounts
of work not just for the two existing
shipyards but for a third significant
Shipyard negotiations will now begin
around the construction of seven new
icebreakers prime minister Justin
Trudeau says the contracts are estimated
to be worth about eight and a half
billion dollars voters in Prince Edward
Island have given Progressive
conservative leader Dennis King a second
term as Premier the PCS won a commanding
majority in yesterday's vote taking 22
of the 27 seats in the legislature
that verdict is that positive politics
is Alive and Well in Prince Edward
Island
the Liberals edged out the green party
as the official opposition by a single
seat
[Music]
Crash Landing next Richard Branson's
multi-billion dollar rocket Company
files for bankruptcy
[Music]
one of the world's most successful and
flamboyant entrepreneurs suffered a
setback today virgin orbit Richard
Branson satellite launching company has
filed for bankruptcy protection Mike
Armstrong explains how a multi-billion
dollar Venture fell back to Earth after
a failed launch earlier this year
it was from day one a bit of a gamble
virgin Orbit's business was sending
small satellites into space not with a
rocket from a Launch Pad but with a
rocket dropped from a modified 747 what
that meant was a launch service that
could go anywhere there was a long
enough Runway if a country had a
satellite to send up Virgin orbit could
go to them which is quite unique usually
you would bring your satellite to a to a
Launcher not the other way around now
what went wrong well the company made
big news back in January with a failed
launch from the UK it appears that
launcher one has suffered an anomaly the
rocket didn't make it out to space and
its cargo including British and American
intelligent satellites ended up in the
ocean absolutely devastated
um you know we put our heart and soul
into this using our launcher one vehicle
even before that high profile failure
the company was already struggling it
had launched four Rockets successfully
and 33 satellites but it wasn't growing
instead it was burning through cash
competition was a problem traditional
Rockets are able to launch more
satellites at a time and of different
sizes big and small the other problem
was the industry times are tough that
they're having a tough ride on the stock
exchange hence why
several launch companies are actually
struggling and not limited to Virgin I
was once a child with a dream Richard
Branson spun virgin orbit off from his
space tourism company Virgin Galactic in
2017. it went public it evaluated
creation of about four billion dollars
as it files for bankruptcy protection in
the last five years it's lost close to
99 of its share price Mike Armstrong
Global News
a competitive field that is global
national for this Tuesday I'm Donna
Friesen tonight's your Canada is Dildo
Newfoundland and Labrador we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to
viewers at globalnational.com and thanks
for watching hope to see you here again
tomorrow bye-bye
foreign
[Music]